الكثير مما نؤمن به عن الحياة يدور
حول القلب ، إنه يتعلق بالحب ، إنه يتعلق
بالشكل الأساسي ، إنه يتعلق بالاتصال
،
هذه الفكرة حية وهي أنه يمكنك البدء في
بناء هذا الحق الذي تعرفه في بعض
النواحي ، فإن النوع البيولوجي من التحدي
غير العادي
هو دوريس تايلور  مبتكر
تحاول أن تفعل شيئًا قال الجميع
إنه مستحيل أن تنمو قلوب بشرية جديدة
فردية
تنتظر آلاف الأشخاص
الذين يحتاجون إلى عمليات زرع قلب
ولا يمكنهم الحصول عليها ،
نستخدم قلب خنزير استخدمنا أساسًا
ما يعادل شامبو الأطفال.
من خلال جميع الأوعية الدموية في
القلب وما تبقى كانت هذه
السقالة التي بدت وكأنها قلب ما
نسميه قلبنا الشبح هذا هو
قلب الشبح هذا هو المكان الذي
يبدأ فيه إذا كنت شخصًا كنت
تفعل هذا لبناء هذا  قلبي
هل سيكون قلبي في النهاية سأبني
لك قلبًا مخصصًا إذا كنت بحاجة إلى
قلب سأأخذ خلايا من دمك
أو من بشرتك.  سأحولها إلى
خلايا جذعية ، ثم أزرع بلايين
الخلايا التي نحتاجها ، أضع خلاياك على
سقالة خنزير وتغطي كل سطح
من تلك السقالة بخلاياك ،
ثم نعلمها كيف تنمو
وتصبح قلبًا متطابقًا  جسدك
أعتقد أن هذه الفكرة الكاملة لتعليم الخلايا
من الصعب أن تدور حولك عندما
تخرج و Jog
ألست تقوم بتعليم الخلايا في
ساقك لتصبح أقوى وهذا
ما أفعله في الأساس أنا فقط أستخدم
المحفز الاصطناعي
وضغط الدم الاصطناعي تذكر المرة الأولى
التي رأيتها تعمل بالفعل ، نعم ، أنت
تعلم أنها إحدى لحظات نعم في
الحياة لا يمكنك اختراع هذه الأشياء بشكل صحيح
على الرغم من أننا فعلنا ذلك نوعًا
ما سأخبرك عنها  رحلة مدتها 20 عامًا
أخبرني الكثير من الناس
أنه لا يمكن القيام بها ، فأنا دائمًا ما أتحقق من
الأخبار على هاتفي وكنت مثل يا
قلبي الشبح اللطيف مثل ما يمكن
أن تكون
ميكايلا باول البالغة من العمر 26 عامًا قد خضعت
لعملية زرع قلب بنفسها الآن  أنقذت حياتها
لكنها "  ليست دوريس الشخصية الصعبة التي
تصف
ميكايلا بأنها في نظام يومي من
الأدوية المضادة للرفض قلقة من أن
جسدها قد يرفض يومًا ما عضوها المتبرع به ،
لقد
ألهمني هذا الفيديو بجنون لدرجة أنه كان علي فقط
أن أرسل رسالة  أشكرك على
إعطائي الأمل وقالت إنها أعتقد أنه
يمكنني يومًا ما أن أعيش حياة طبيعية
يا إلهي في
كثير من الأحيان لا نسمع القصة
وراء القصة
لفهم الأشخاص الذين يصنعون هذه التطورات
حقًا وأقول شيئًا آخر  تلك
القصة التي لم يتم إخبارها كثيرًا ، إنها
فتاة مثلي الجنس نشأت في ولاية ميسيسيبي وتم
طردها من الكلية في الواقع
لكونها مثليًا
لم أكن لأفكر أبدًا في أنني
سأقف على هذه المرحلة أفعل شيئًا
كهذا ، لذا شكرًا لك هل يمكنك تخيل
أنها  قيل لك ليس فقط أنه لا يمكنك
متابعة أحلامك العلمية ،
بل لن أمنحك حتى درجة علمية ،
حلاً لواحدة من أكبر المشاكل
في العالم تقريبًا لم يحدث
بسبب هويتها بالنسبة لجميع الأشخاص  le
الذين ما زالوا يقولون لا ، إنهم يعرفون أننا سنقوم
بذلك أولاً في الخنازير ،
ثم سنذهب إلى الناس
كل يوم لا نصل إلى هناك ،
ويموت شخص آخر
، وسيعمل
علي أن ألمس قلبًا تم
إنشاؤه
بواسطة دوريس
اليوم  هناك مكان يتقاطع فيه العلم
والروحانية حقًا ،
وأعتقد أنه على الأرجح في مكان مثل هذا ،
قال لي شخص آخر إنك لا
تبني أوريغون أنت تبني الأمل